hey guys how's it going so this is kind
of a bitter say I am making a video
reacting to some of my old vine now I
was never really a liner per se because
I love Twitter and I loved you too but
this is kind of merging those two
together sort of creating a short little
snippet of what I would normally do on
YouTube bringing it over to your vine
and then posting the vines on Twitter so
for me it's kind of I don't know man I
was I was really into vine for a long
time my sister Jenna was probably so
happy to get out of anybody when the
vine fad sort of started the window at
least for me because she is taught to
fill my vine all the time no matter
where we were we were at the mall we'd
be anywhere I was like I've got an idea
we got to do this so if you never used
vine will chew late because it's no
longer with us anymore but they are
going to be turning vine into a camera
app so essentially you'll be able to
make vines and then save them to your
camera roll and then post them on
twitter or post them wherever it is the
you posting so at least vine in all of
its sense of the app will still sort of
be preserved let's take a peek at some
of my old vines I am sitting here on my
little vine page vine was from January
2013 to January 2017 oh I'm not even
that long the time really the business
of my newest ones I post is this one not
too long around look check gainful you
know what a baby it was kind of after he
got neutered so he gained a little
weight he looks a little puppy Christian
this is good hair nobody oh he's so
perfect this is like my favorite video
ever
my sweet sweet I love my dog my prince
he was no little guy he was so so little
you on the dress oh my god
alright let's go back to my oldest vines
I want to show you guys the first time
that I ever posted this was Wow January
25th 2013
boy it's really good they hope this is
backward with still stop-motion what
you're so stupid
these are still dumb we call a duty back
when call of duty was good oh god what's
this
this one's from filming a Taco Bell
commercial I think
Melia water Oh making this movie that's
the last time I ate something healthy oh
my god I used to be so fit in 2013
look at this I was making like salads I
was going for walk I was meeting fresh
fruit I would hang out that
with the Xbox is one of the no can you
even I can't believe it was an another
pop conference and little did I know
years later I would actually meet Jimmy
a moto I'm in New York right now and
it's raining and I skinning schoolers
Brett fresh fresh fresh fresh feel fresh
how fresh oh my god I gotta skip through
some of these if there's a lot oh my god
I used to do this treasure work so at
this point in my vine career I would say
I was actually trying to see how many
followers I could lose by being super
annoying
oh hi I bet you're expecting me to be
really annoying guess what I'm not just
waste my life away watch technically
work the opposite way because people
started following me more even though
trying to lose followers although people
that I think I actually might have cared
about probably left
more snow on 2013 guys oh god this is
the best I remember this one your sewing
foot CC on the fly yet even a teen get
it Porto's diligence even a key I got a
tweet this I got a sweet this it so
agree all this is my kitty this is like
18 she passed away so let's go tired I'm
disgusted by my own self-directed Liu
shuffle someone's together gizmo he
passed away too
oh god this is so painful I hate it
obviously with this coaster every time a
little dancing we went and we met in the
mustache cat eye golf so skilled
Oh Mario Kart my birthday party
this is we were shooting fire the Living
Dead here's another clip well we thought
this is when I was real into
skateboarding I've had a lot of failed a
lot of failed hobbies back when I wasn't
there be a passionate like when I was
trickshotting
in the overtime leave extra holbrook I
miss mine I had the best time like this
was fun it was fun
there's not like those normal at this
point in time I was then uploading vines
or editing them on iMovie Rob promise I
said deferred and he is a super popular
Viner always made the most creative and
awesome vine
Aaron what the current use alternative
is nice you guys oh my god we slept
outside the Apple store hold up to the
city with not seeing the missus or like
erotic dogs is beau a beautiful boy oh
my god I'm oh this is like I'm going
through like my family crap Bob so again
I'm like honey hide itself beyond that
sight don't worry almost there just hold
on a little bit more ah trying to be
healthy real into this trap
it couldn't be more in the park I'll be
having fun so the business of locusts
Roy yeah think about that for a second
just put in the back of your mind and
think about it God he's gone $199
okay let's look at my most popular ones
now watch out Bobby showing a horizontal
disruptive thought I put a bottom now
we're here
surfing music lucky I don't want you
call God's work is John cuz I'm a target
little known fact that can bark like a
dog I was barking it another dog
he say resign this
[Music]
I was getting pumped up for the Apple
watch you guys do you think of my new
Apple watch well guys I think that does
it for pretty much some of my most
popular vines and just a little look
back into the history of last four years
of my mind I hope you don't judge me and
if you do judge me that's totally cool
because I think I deserve it
well thank you guys for watching I hope
you guys enjoyed this and it'll sorta
see what happens to Lowe's divine I hope
it'll be a cool app so then I see you
guys later here on YouTube and Twitter
and Instagram and snapchat Facebook my
missing anything like what apps are you
guys using now and you something new on
board say bye
[Music]
Oh